this over here is a picture of the
Constitutional Convention which we
mentioned happened in 1787 the original
intent of the Constitutional Convention
was to revise the Articles of
Confederation but folks like Alexander
Hamilton and James Madison really wanted
to replace the Articles of Confederation
you can see it's being presided over by
George Washington and it starts the
preamble says we the people of the
United States in order to form a more
perfect union establish justice insure
domestic tranquility provide for the
common defense promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and our posterity
do ordain and establish this
constitution for the United States of
America so once again pause this video
and think about whether you see ideas of
popular sovereignty limited government
social contract natural rights going on
even in this preamble or even from the
fact that they took the trouble to
create this constitution well let's
start at the beginning so it starts with
we the people we the people are the ones
that are creating this constitution and
not only it does it start with we the
people but we the people is
intentionally written in this very very
large writing right over here this is a
picture of the Constitution so it's
really all about We the People the
people are sovereign so this idea of
popular sovereignty comes out loud and
clear in not just the Declaration of
Independence but also the US
Constitution and the fact that we the
people are setting up this government
this is all about social contract they
are forming a government they're forming
a social contract with a government that
is going to protect that is going to
establish justice provide for the common
defense promote the general welfare so
let me make this clear that is this this
is all social contract this is what we
expect this government that we're
creating to do promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and our posterity
now what about things like limited
government well just the very fact
that we have a constitution is a sign of
limited government that it isn't just a
pure democracy that whoever is governing
is going to be constrained there the
rights of the government are going to be
described by this constitution we also
talked about the blessings of liberty so
this is another reference to natural
rights the Declaration of Independence
is a little bit more clear about natural
rights are a little bit more explicit
but the blessings of liberty does talk
about or that's maybe in reference to
natural rights and so I will leave you
there
as we study US government both the
Declaration of Independence and even
more so the US Constitution are going to
be things that we keep going back to to
understand how we are trying to form a
more perfect union and what is in line
with the vision of our founding fathers
and what isn't